How are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his brief News Now newsletter in
Spanish There are second-dose vaccines
available for walk-ins at the
convention center People who
have received the first dose of the
modern vaccine at some of the centers in
the district of  health of the south of high
and still do not have an appointment can arrive at
the convention center to request the
officials remind the public that
people arriving at the clinic must
have received the first dose of
modern between the dates of January 4 to 9
if you have any  questions
about the second dose vaccination process you
can call the
helpline at 70 27 59 1900
some county leaders seek to
loosen coronavirus restrictions
locally a new proposal led
by commissioner may blanco thatcher
proposes expanding
capacity limits  in public meetings at 50%, the
commissioner said that
the proposal would depend on the trend of each case
It would be presented to the governor and the
state command for mitigation against the
coronavirus
and as the saying goes there is no date that is
not met or deadline that is not expired the
anticipated celebration of the scientific super point
55 for this Sunday and all
the excitement of the superbowl is set  It can
be seen on our channel 8 where
the confrontation between the
Kansas City Chiefs and the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers will be broadcast, who will play for the NFL title.
The game starts at 3:30
in the afternoon on Sunday and our
teams will also be following  and
updating all the game action
on our pages and social networks the
news now in spanish the national
soccer league is allowing each team
in the league to invite four people from
their cities to the superbowl
las vegas' videos invited four residents
from the valley to go to the big game the
lucky ones who are heading to traps are
health sector workers that
include doctors cha  rlín edwin
orlando or if nicolás calica and the
disease same before valls omo
congratulations to all of them and we pass with
the temperatures for our region
today is expected to be a warm and
sunny day as well as temperatures in
the high 60s the clouds will return for
the  start of next week despite the fact
that
several days of pleasant temperatures
I am Cristian Cáceres and he suffered
from News Now in Spanish Happy
Friday